[Music]
and welcome back to another awesome
episode of the careful boys where today
we have
[Applause]
Nick okay we got Giani
here I'm not I'm
[Applause]
not that great you ever heard that
Applause before that's a JK
original oh we like that one that's yeah
that's also a JK original what is that
that's a panther yeah it's a bacteria
Center don't tou it's a don't touch
it wuh virus Center dude's lips have
been on it ta lip where Co started what
did you just hear I I heard what did you
hear I heard what did you hear I'm not
going to say it did you hear Wuhan
somewhere I did hear that yeah but that
wasn't just me was it in this side of
the room or was it over there somewhere
it was more in the white side
I couldn't be more white okay so
speaking of good transition if if you
could play any instrument or learn any
language in 2 hours which would you
choose in one that's a [__] great
question you like piano the best piano
hands down wow piano your hands are
[Laughter]
down you be like
Ryan I feel like that's the like
ultimate if you know piano you under you
really understand music theory and then
now you could play any other instrument
and with modern technology like if you
have those [__] corg keyboards you
could play You Go guitar now it's guitar
or [__] Harps a chord or whatever but
then there's no flip to that there's no
guitar that goes click piano and then
now it's
piano so like if you can play piano you
can score a movie you can go [__]
horns too get AAR yeah you can do
whatever and now you could do the whole
what instrument get you the
most you know what is that balls yeah
balls what instrument get you the most P
this one right here definitely that one
but there's no hair on those balls so
when you blow that one dude I know it's
kind of working oh yeah how many
different things do you have
[Laughter]
over Dude I didn't know I was guest
stting on Sesame Street today what the
[__] I didn't even know you had
that why don't use that more bro yeah
that look way more fun it's crazy to
hear it in like person right right right
yeah every time someone makes a [__]
joke you just go that was the best debut
of that instrument [__] I should be on a
court keyboard dude we've all been SE
for hell long he hasn't pulled that out
once how long has this show been going
on dude how long you over 10 years over
10 years he's he's literally been
waiting for that moment for like 10 he
goes
now what a setup
bro holy [__] this episode's brought to
you by
Joe yeah piano for me so it's either you
learn an instrument or a language or a
language in 2 hours wow in two hours
yeah yeah yeah
skateboard I'm going skateboard that's
kind of tight that's kind of fresh [__]
it's an instrument of your feet dog
who's your top skatebo who's your
favorite um I don't know many of them I
know uh Tony Hawk so you'd want to be
like do know like no I'm actually just
kidding I was just I literally saw a
skateboard behind you guys I was like
skatebo the black dude yeah NAA is that
his name naaya not naaya I thought
that's how you spell it n i j i a h n he
he hooked up with a girl I like I don't
talk about that
guy [__] yeah n y j a h you're right n
NAA H what about him that is nasty too
skateboarder yeah he's pretty cool yeah
he's really good
he's the he's like the bad boy of
skateboard oh really the bad boy bad boy
was
that you don't like that not
English Okay final answer I'm
like I don't know just not English
English would you rather learn a new
language or a instrument that's hard bro
a language probably really for me yeah
cuz I picked up piano during Co did you
like I don't need to know no no no I
have plenty to still learn but I could
play like a good like 10 12 songs oh wow
lot no no no like actual songs I can't
do that cuz like when you go to like an
actual teacher they start you on like
stuff like that I can't learn like that
um so do you know like Theory or are you
like self taught on songs self taught on
songs so it's like choreography with
your fingers got it um I would love to
learn theory but for language probably
the language of my people Chinese
oh Mandarin C I think she's [__] with
me I don't is it true or not she has
that it's in the eyes look at the eyes
look how squinty them things are no she
has Chinese cheeks Chinese colen Chinese
you know it's in there what eyes we all
look the
same talking oh I don't like
this I don't like this this sounds
racist yeah I don't like no no no I was
doing the opposite you sing isid freaks
it's it's like it's like I don't see
color yeah yeah that's I was going to
say I don't see color like okay dude
whatever you round eye bro there round
ey they're [__] bold these people not
on my watch that's my answer a new
language would be cool language I think
yeah what
language um
and if oh so I want to learn um well I
want to be better at Japanese but I
already know Japanese I just suck at it
I think I would learn Welsh oh really
yeah I thought that was an accent Welsh
is a language it's a language bro it's
like gay I mean there's like 15 people
that speak Welsh I know that is going to
be like that's the most unuseful thing
you could ever ask for but that's
because uh my wife is Welsh right okay
so then like from it dude she and she
doesn't speak English at all so like
that way they can communicate finally we
can communicate she's got a cool ass
[__] accent though huh she sounds
Northern but then it's not so cool
because she went to London and then it
sounds and [__] it all up yeah she
doesn't sound as Northern anymore but um
I think it would be a good secret
language cuz not a lot of people
understand it oh you could talk to her
in public and no one picks it up I learn
we both will learn Welsh together but
also she so she don't even know Welsh
she knows like a few words I think she
knows more French the Welsh people don't
even know
Welsh yeah we speak English
mate what ACC is that dud yeah I know
that one Irish that's Chinese that's
Korean you sound like you're from
London what what's a Welsh word do you
know any Welsh like phrases I think
there was this one city it was like
kin oh wow and I was like now you're
[__] being racist to us now you
Pricks are being racist to us in the
educational realm okay this is all for
education I don't know if I pronounced
it oh it's all for educational purposes
great
his
butthole one's enough that's
fair it sounds crazy though it's it's
it's uh it just sounds wild and I'm like
how did okay like you know how Scottish
and and Irish and like um Welsh folks
have an accent right that's cuz they had
a different language and they learned
English so that's is that's why their
English is all like it's just like being
Cho here is that actually why mhm they
have their own language and
then but then I I just thought it was a
a weird like crazy thing to learn and
then and it's also like preserving it so
like that's pretty cool cuz it's up to
Joe to preserve the Welsh culture but I
don't I think that's wrong because
British people never had a a another
language English yeah but they there was
an old you know there's an older English
sounds very very different it's not a
Korean you said hello
in that's what I thought you said for a
second there's old you guys well I mean
gaic is a thing well cuz no it's cuz
England conquered whales and then made
them wipe out their culture that's why a
lot of them kind of didn't speak it is
confusing cuz they all look the
same you know what I mean finally
someone said it oh I'm saying it and in
Scottish people they spoke their own
Scottish gay like until they joined the
United Kingdom who are the Celtics yeah
yeah the Celtics are the ancient whites
the ancient whites the ancient whites
and they got taken over by the English
too I think Celtics or Celtics no
because like you know the Roman Empire
yeah when they conquered England or that
southern area before it was England or
whatever that was like the dominant
people so it's all just like all these
mixed folks yeah cuz they also got
raided by Vikings and [__] and so yeah
they're all named Sven Sven Sven yeah
who are they the Norse and ol yeah I
don't like where this is going dude yeah
we're just dunking on G I can't even say
anything back just kidding I wasn't even
thinking anything what would you want
instrument or [__] language dude I
feel like I need to speak the language
of my people which is you know how to
speak chines what's his people what's
his people yeah what's my people GI
American
right safe pretty close very close so
you're saying he doesn't speak English
well [__] I can't win I don't um uh yes
dude it's probably exactly what you're
thinking whatever you're thinking just
say it in his head he's like I was going
to say Chinese yeah call me a ching
chong dude no dude I said Chinese you're
going to change all the [__] I was like
what is it it's like all we just need to
we just need you to say ching chong once
so we can it over yeah so Ryan can cut
up nice song CH they're like who's the
song that sings who's the guy that sings
holiday and I'm like Chingy they're like
Bingo we
need I think speaking Mandarin would be
[__] tight like I would need you
can't speak any Chinese not really like
I understand it here and there but like
by the time my parents well by the time
I was born cuz I have a big gap with my
sisters they kind of were growing up
they grew up speaking it a little bit
more and then they didn't even [__]
try with me like yeah this [__]
can't even read English so we need to
focus on that first and that was like a
real thing actually so then like his
hands keep going like this like put him
down let's not give him let's not
overload his small brain let's give to
him's just hand feed
him vict like whoa whoa whoa he just did
an arm bar do
that words is not his strength let's not
do
more so I think probably that but I
would always like learning instrument is
so [__] cool it's you know how to do
musical stuff like I play guitar for a
little bit but I wasn't like that good I
just play violin obviously that's hard I
hear it's really hard viol is but it's
like you give me violin now I don't know
what the [__] am I going to learn I know
how to put rosin on it I know how to do
that dud like imagine like cuz that's a
cool one where like 2 hours you could be
fun with it you could be you could be oh
I want to do this weird thing because
it's it won't it's not too much of my
time dude imagine knowing the [__]
harp that would be hilarious wheeling in
this massive instrument
like [__] watch this and every's like
okay cool having to transport weirdo
this is a weird vibe you're good yeah
like that'll shut everyone up that's a
show stoer ceiling is entertaining
people at the hallway of the
bagio the height of your career dude if
James Brown got popular cuz he was
playing the [__] harp you know he he
wasn't Bart troll ass is going to come
in with a keyboard and PR harp check
this out dude I think playing instrument
is [__] way cooler than learning a
language though I you can aspire to be
the transition for live shows as a heart
person dude cuz dude as they close the
curtain you play the heart and you tell
them like what happened during this time
and [__] definitely you know how like
you were saying that if you ask anybody
on the street if they wanted to be in a
movie it' Always Be yes I feel like it'd
be the same thing if you could be like a
rock star or rapper sure player yeah
like you see see [__] y mom when he
starts playing his uh his dude it looks
like he's masturbating bro but it's like
you feel like you can't help but to feel
something even though you don't
instrument you're like this is the cool
imagine someone runs up to you on the
street you're like you want to play the
harp you're like I don't know not really
no said everybody wants to play the
har stop yelling at me it's very
instrument dependent you know but like
just to be a crazy musician like I think
that's everyone's [__] like everybody
wants a piece of that yeah yeah you know
and there's so many talented just
singers music just like just like a
drunk uncle that doesn't even do it for
money yeah like they can just go all of
a sudden you're just like wow this is
amazing well you think about you think
about like some of the funniest people
you've ever met don't even do
entertainment that's true like oh yeah
you know I mean that's true and you go
you could be a star one day and then
they're like I'm too
shy I don't like crowds they're like
just I like Enterprise like I I love
this place yeah I can't who's gonna work
who's going to take this over if I if I
become a
huge I think rational answer will also
be learned Chinese cuz it's like useful
as [__] in my family you don't Chinese
more than the music wait I thought you
do rational I thought you speak M I know
I know a couple phrases in context but
other than that like if I if I knew
Mandarin I'd be probably way crazier in
China business right now what do you
speak at home already crazy Vietnamese
oh but don't they speak English over
there with you with all the business
stuff no I'm not everybody for sure not
everybody a lot of people are very okay
at English how come I'm I'm hella fluent
and I got zero business over there well
it's because your business is okay what
do you mean my business sucks hey you
know what do you want to do business in
China is there money yeah it's China
though that's the that's the trade wait
why you making that face talk to Chinese
Japanese that's
why
I'm counting I'm going one two three
four try it try it
no he'll teach you so that's rational
but for the fun ching chong CH
no is that actually it all right bait
him ching chong bing bong is the next
oneing
long I've heard that before that's the
even
numbers long Ting Tong long but in two
hours so was silly it would be the
saxophone bro sax is kind of night bro I
[__] like that answer dude [__] you
guys he's cool as [__] dude [__] the
keyboard bro you know what's funny I you
inspired by Bill Clinton I tried to get
that's one way to look at it I tried to
um Lisa Simpson I tried to get uh a I
got a saxophone off Amazon for like 299
bucks one time like years ago cuz I was
like yo I'm going to just try and pick
this up and then I was annoying as [__]
in my apartment in the H BR they're
going to kick you out dude yeah and then
after that I just never did it
again it's loud that's why who's this
guy playing this beautiful music like
you know what I mean when you suck in
the beginning cuz like glowing into the
saliva's going everywhere and you just
can't moosey he's like the saliva's
going every I'm like relax over
there that that was very immature I'm
sorry go on I cut you off I forgot what
I was about to say it's okay I want to
learn Vietnamese too so I feel like I
should hop on the van why why Vietnamese
just cuz everyone said it dude imagine
if I was like I want to learn [__]
German everyone's like oh
relax I got to go Viet what about
Italian sounds so tough yeah Italian
seems beautiful you you you know what's
weird I don't even like that language or
like people or like Italian women like
it's not kind of like my really what
about the food the food's great don't
get me wrong but also I ate pasta and
piz my whole life make the food too no
no men make food too see you do like
Italians yeah most of the cooks in Italy
are are men yeah um cuz I feel like
cooking in Italy is like an actual like
it's like a big deal right it's so
strict and I'm not saying that women
can't do be big deals why you don't
like you think women can't cook that's
crazy you don't think Italian women can
cook so what do you like Chinese so what
do you like I like everything about
Chinese women you're your thoughts
opinions if you're not if you don't
gravitate toward Italian stuff what what
do you gravitate toward if if you were
to like put a gun in my head and say
tell me what you like I don't have a
type but like tell me what you think the
most beautiful woman like you know type
in the world I would say like Middle
Eastern like Lebanese um like that style
of women like you're a big schwarma
lover I I do love the food um but like
yeah the leban like the Middle Eastern
women are like like Arab oh my God
forget why you got to put a gun to your
head to say that oh because I feel like
that you would force me to say something
you know go you or if you had a video of
me saying ching chong like oh we got it
we got it
got it's locked in do not delete this
Ching CH and repeat it too ching chong
ch ch ch ch put it on a
loop clip that with the butthole video
next is him doing this bro if we get him
to do this that area of the world that's
honestly that's the one place that like
I want to go to like Israel and like um
the Middle East but it's like a lot of
those places are dangerous if you don't
know anyone you know what I mean you're
going to do a world [__] tour
I just came back from one Europe but I
did a European one yeah I do want
there's a lot of brown folks in the
europs so yeah a lot in London a lot
like yeah you see how big his eyes got
he was like a lot in London they're
they're out there open up eyes just stop
dude I'm trying to just jealous I wish I
had that range of motion
myol the mobility in our
eyes it just doesn't go I do eye ups
every morning
that's that's what the white people
aren't saying we have to do eye UPS
just stare like that God one day one
day